the Joe Rogan experience it what
yeah the Schultz thing was really cool
to see because she just did it on his
own yep and it's here's the thing and I
wanted to bring this up with you Jamie
is he
shadow banned on Instagram tell me what
you think is going on because I texted
him when that happened cuz I looked it
up yes and his name's show up her at the
top of my list but but he said other
people me yeah well you wouldn't show
her mine really yes I think it changed
the algorithm because I've noticed a
woman it could be what it could be but
there you have to take it like a case by
case scenario was the person that first
sentence him are they already following
him do they search his name a lot
did they block anything has ever done
people have told him hey man I'm having
a hard time finding your Instagram page
and so he asked me about it and I said
what do you mean and I go I'm you I see
you right now you're on my feed and he
goes no no if you go to search me so he
let me search you I know why whoa i
searched Andrew Schultz nothing I mean a
bunch of other people but not him and
he's got a lot of followers like good
let's do it right now
pull it up put it up on screen okay put
it up on the screen let's just do it in
real time let this part of what I was
saying as I follow him so if you're not
already follow up in a different way but
I do follow him oh now just right Andrew
and give him some space right space as I
got in space already right but just
space and then put it type in his name
and it's not coming up right oh that's
so sad now hit Search
I don't think good you can't search on
No Oh on the web but look it's not
showing up
you see Andrew Schultz fans even when I
typed in his account name it didn't show
up Oh hold on it's a good what is that
Andrew Schultz fans what does that click
on that right there below it blow it
below it blow it keep going keep going
the blind count there it is that's right
click on that I know but it's not so
it's his fans I just have made 165
followers and that's crazy
right no I know it's not him I'm just
trying to figure out what it is so just
in that search it's not showing up and
it wouldn't show up for me on my phone
either now it doesn't make any sense
because what does he have like a
half a million followers how many
fathers yeah not interesting yeah like
he thinks he's being shadow banned
what's the are they trying to get some
money out of no two hundred eighty two
thousand two hundred eighty two thousand
people and he can't find his page
Instagram is it Schultz with the tea or
no just no no no ulz but it's not
showing up it is not showing about my
knee and now we might be being paranoid
here and it might be just something in
the search algorithm that for whatever
reason his thing isn't showing up and he
used to say Andrew hesays Schultz I
don't know why has he was that name if
it's okay and maybe he thought that
Hesse was [ __ ] him up so he took
Hesse out of his name in the it I was
Instagram page so it just says Andrew
Schultz now but even though still you
can't find it yeah that's weird you have
to type in Andrew Scholes altogether
with no space and then you'll find them
it that's what I just didn't didn't come
up with no space yeah that's why we're
just doing in front while you were to
asking me to type stuff and I was like
oh so you did it with space and no space
that's when I did it to him I was like
if you're typing in no space that's
where the issue is if I'd leave that
know if I'd type in all the way it's
showing up right away and he said well
I'm seeing that from people both ways so
I go off if that's what you're seeing
then I'll go out on a limb and sort of
say does your show one is manipulating
that search result because you can't
manipulate search result well here's the
thing they do
Shadowman people on certain social media
platforms this has been revealed through
hidden-camera conversations with people
who are whatever moderators or engineers
or people that work behind the scenes on
twitter or facebook and they they do
manipulate algorithms manipulate
searches and and shadow van people and
there's a lot of people particularly
conservative people which he's not
conservative but what he is is you know
he's a raunchy comedian and he might
have done something that someone felt
was not woke or what have you and they
want to slow down the broadcasting of a
signal that's entirely possible
i don't know if it's true though
I would love to have a logical
explanation that it's the line he's not
showing up yes but he's you know he's
complaining about it that it's a shadow
band anyway
go follow Andrew Andrew Schultz yeah s s
hu LZ s hu LZ go follow yes I Montreal
just tell Instagram shadow bands we can
get around you [ __ ] he's a marketing
genius it's just great to hear him talk
about you know what he's doing and I got
to get around it and it's exciting
because you you forget as an artist that
you have a lot of power a year
everything your your the product and hmm
something's especially in the old model
you just kind of waited to be anointed
well he's got millions and millions of
views on his special on YouTube and if
you stop and think about if that was on
Comedy Central which Comedy Central
didn't want to give him special he
probably would get like maybe a million
people would watch it when it came out
and that would be the end of it I have a
special and I don't think people are
watching it just YouTube is accessible
it can be in comedy jail you could do a
great special and no one can find it
right yeah yeah and everyone has YouTube
everyone can click on the link everyone
has you do and this was his logic he was
like you know what I'm just gonna
release the whole thing on YouTube and
look he went straight from not selling
out clubs to selling out theaters like
that and now he sells out everywhere
internationally